did you watch ufc 266. did watch you
you're watching your green room or did
you watch it i watched it in my green
room in fact and i watched uh and i i
think i was so impressed with nick diaz
i just his boxing and his you know i
thought he did a great job but um
i just think you know he broke his nose
i think he got hit too hard and he was
like
i don't want this anymore
i don't want to do this i'm going to
take a seat yeah and he's the only he's
one of the few people that can quit and
we just go you're still such a badass
yeah i mean online he's getting
transferred people call him twitter
which is weird hilarious yeah which is
so stupid that guy's earned that but
also took six years off and then going
into the fight he was nervous i was
talking with our boy about it i'm like
man diaz seems off he's like no that's
why we love diaz typical stuff i'm like
no he really doesn't seem like he wants
to do it this time and they see in the
fight like he showed a good fight
definitely looked like took six years
off definitely looked 38. like that
wasn't a young vintage nick diaz
and i think
there are some red flags was telling
chin on blow about there's all these red
flags leading up to it and we're just
like ah nick diaz he'll be fine and then
he gets in there why because he was
basically saying i don't want to fight
he said that before and then he's game
once he gets in there he just hates all
the build up yeah but then you see like
when he was in lockdown he almost forgot
to take his shirt off and get vaseline
so you're like right he's not mentally
checked in and then he gets in there and
then usually he's like scowling at the
guy and like look at him like flip him
off no matter who it is this time he's
looking at the mat most times he's
looking at the mat and then you know
through that weird wheel kick that you
could throw you know and then stats yeah
just kind of taking shots and then i
think the other red flag is the ufc made
it five rounds
why the [ __ ] would you make it five
rounds guys stay back in six years how
crazy is that so i think with nick i
don't think he's quitting he's like
he's alright i've thrown so much volume
at this guy he's not going he's coming
forward i'm getting hit with shots yeah
all right and i have two more rounds i'm
not dude i'm not and he's very conscious
of ct and injury he's like [ __ ] this how
much and then also what else and i'd
love to know the back story jake shields
came out was like nick's such a you know
legend he took this on six weeks notice
he didn't say he didn't want to take the
fight but someone was like oh you can't
think nick didn't want to be in there
and drake just responded back snakes
everywhere
i mean like you you know like people
forced to because he got i think he was
the highest paid on the card wow so
there's something i love that he got
paid but you can see his face he's taken
a [ __ ] load of damage over the years
you're talking about a guy who's never
stopped
working out by the way in training he's
been he's been boxing marathons yeah if
he's been boxing i think he has been
boxing too i was very impressed with his
boxing actually i thought he connected a
shitload with robbie long that's pop-pop
like
one of robbie's for five of his is the
way it goes yeah like you're just
robbie's robbie does
he head hunts yeah he's a killer yes a
monster yeah i just yeah i think people
got to realize too you know we're like
oh he did it for money yeah
everybody in here everybody in here okay
you guys can get paid if you don't have
to come in nobody's coming in
so for him it's like yeah of course he
got a paid it's a [ __ ] job but then
also
because he has such a loyal fault in
following stuff like that it's also like
you know when he was big in his prime
guys weren't getting paid dude so he
can't just ride off on the sunset and
count his dollars like he needs this
money he sees his brother getting big
money and he's like what the [ __ ] the
biggest money yeah fine conor yeah so so
he's like so it makes financial sense i
do not think he would ever fight if he
didn't kind of have to or didn't see
millions of dollars and i will always
watch but i want to know what's going on
with his team i don't know if you see
nick diaz again i don't know i don't
think his team i don't think anybody can
control nick diaz i think nick diaz's
genius is the the fact that he's just
such a
such an anomaly he's such a and that's
fine but yeah and then those fighters
end up broke with ct that's right so he
needs people around him who need to set
things up for him so that brings me to
the brian ortega fight
and he's only lost two fights
yeah he's taking a lot of damage and he
should have that and i in my opinion
this is a incredibly talented fighter
you know he's willing to die in there
and i think that fight should have been
stopped oh and then the third [ __ ]
round no
because he got the guilty and then you
got the triangle i don't give a [ __ ]
so he took so much damage not a title he
was taking crazy damage and i don't see
i don't think the juice is worth the
squeeze you take you you could possibly
first of all you got brain damage you
also can take a lot of time off his life
in that fight yes he might get lucky he
wasn't getting beat up that bad really
should have stopped that his face okay
so so all i know is this the doctor was
there for at least a minute longer herb
dean cameron was what's going on because
apparently he was answering the
questions wrong when they were doing
this
he was asking him just to follow with
his eyes keep his head still he went
like that that's a sign that something's
going on you're not seeing things i just
hate scenes you can't do that fight you
can't you just can't oh man well that
and this ain't for you no i'm saying
it's not for you it's not for me that's
why then then i like boxing more because
boxers are boxing if you're getting your
head kicked in like that they'd stop the
fight and for me if you've got it it's
the rodriguez thing you got a young guy
like that with that much promise that
much marketability as your corner oh and
i'm sorry also they had to help them off
the campus which is illegal if your team
have to help you off it's called a tko
you're not allowed to do that they
helped him off nobody saw that and they
walked him back to the thing and i i in
my opinion this kid's gonna fight every
time but i think he was like how do i
deal with this [ __ ] pressure you know
he's not dealing with the pressure well
who
uh ortega yes he answered back but that
[ __ ] volonoski for whatever reason on
that night is a killer and is and is
putting that kind of pressure on that so
do you just always throw in the towel
when it's not going your way when it's
when it's a one is a kid with that much
fight so let's stop at 100 percent so
here's the thing so let's say we take
your thing and you could not be a coach
for this reason so brian ortega his
first fight his first five fights in ufc
he was down on all score cards right and
pulled off the submission in the third
round cool and that's how you got the
title i got you so you almost did it
again so yep almost different this is mo
so now let's go off what you want to do
he wouldn't have a career you would have
stopped those fights before he pulled it
off well it was just you've been first i
was stopped he did have a fight what was
it against uh
uh max max so that was that was smart
they stopped that taking that kind of
damage when i see when i see his head
that swollen and he's not answering
questions properly i'm stopping that
fight and i'm stopping that fight the
the audience wants to fight they're
they're laughing with blood in their
mouth i get it at the end of the day i
see brain damage and i see taking years
off his career now he won that fifth
round
i do not care and look at his face so
boxing would stop that we're just going
off his face
yeah he was taking such a beating no now
real quick um there's been more deaths
than boxing than there's mma just yeah
that's fine that's fine way more very
close but boxing's also been around
longer there's a lot of things about
boxing i've seen it
hold on no hold on there's been more
deaths in boxing in the past five years
than there has been mma yeah there was a
recent one where they they i can't
remember the boxer's name they uh his uh
corner had stopped the fight and dude
ended up dying
maybe that night or like the next the
next day or something like that you're
the the point of boxing is constantly
hitting with mma you got wrestling it's
three rounds yeah yeah yeah but the
points
but like so those fights you were
talking about was he was he getting as
much damage as he was on which one's
fine well the ones where you said hit
you he scored low he's getting [ __ ] up
yeah he's been he's going to go
he pulls it out because his submission
is insane yeah okay yeah and he almost i
mean volkanovsky said in the
post press conference he's like that's
the closest i've ever been there being
choked out yeah he's like i was gargling
and
he's like give me my head i was like
well this is how it goes yeah i'm gonna
lose my belt here we go and he's like by
the
grace of god willpower i powered through
and he let go so this corner probably
just knows like oh or this is ortega so
again it's actually to my point ortega
is insanely talented yeah could be a
champion not yet maybe could be or
certainly will always be that guy with
that crazy game so what you do is you
stop the fight you start to fight in the
third round he wants to keep fighting
everybody's like what the [ __ ] you
should have kept it going for this
reason you have more fight left in you i
don't know what those two rounds where
he was taking another hundred shots to
the head is going to do to his long term
career it's just not the game it's just
not it's got to be the game it's not the
game it should be the game then don't
watch fighting no you're wrong i'm sorry
you won the fifth round
it doesn't does that means he still
could compete at what cost are you
talking again you so you're worried
about guys getting hurt i'm worried
about the us i'm worried about i'm
worried about what you see when you see
a dude who's not for whatever reason oh
don't sign up for that you don't don't
sign up all of us sign up for that no
not that kind of if your corner can't
find your corner third round yes if your
corner can't see that you're getting
your head kicked in that way then
there's something wrong
it because because you you can
you have a lot more fight left there are
more fights for him now we want to see
it now we go like this business-wise
even even business-wise we just stopped
that finally you start that [ __ ]
fight we want to see that again oh no
you know that's what you don't know the
usc like no the ufc go you're never
going to title fight again you're down
on the cards and getting beat and you're
throwing the towel he's never gonna get
top shot again that's not the way that
that works what do you mean because they
stopped it yes
yeah dana's gonna punish the corner
guarantee it
guarantee it i don't know about that if
you're just throwing the towel every
time your fighters lose that's how every
time i'm talking about when your
fighter's getting [ __ ] crushed in the
head like that and he wakes and he walks
up and he can't see and they have to
take an extra minute and a half or
whatever to ask him because he's
answering questions wrong get the [ __ ]
out of here herb dean had to come over
there and herb dean is not allowed to do
this so two things happen two things
happen that are illegal one herb dean
said how many fingers do i have up he
holds up one okay the second thing i
heard that's not illegal i don't believe
the rest is allowed
of course i don't think the reference
no he doesn't herb can do that and if he
says i can't see they bring in the
doctor yeah and then if the doctor does
it and he says i can't stop the fight
first of all the doctor was taking a
long time
in my opinion the doctor was there
asking them questions okay something was
going on and vogue volanosky said yeah
he was answering the questions wrong
that's why herb dean came over and goes
what's going on that's what he says okay
so now then i hear brian ortega go yeah
i'll be all right or something like that
to me man it was just it was and the
biggest thing is when i saw them have to
help him off the mat and walk him to the
stool
get the [ __ ] out of here man i was like
that's like in between rounds yeah that
could be exhaustion i would suggest also
that if you want to do that okay i think
that took i think that's short in his
career and is that worth it okay and if
you say that's the game
i don't agree but okay
but what if you ask brian ortega he says
going to stop that fired all you you
don't ask that [ __ ] he's a
warrior he'll die on there that's not
who you ask never ask a fighter they'll
die so you ask the coaches yes yes the
the coaches are there to protect you the
coaches should see that that is live to
fight another day you're young you're a
badass you have a huge market share
let's protect the goose that lays the
golden egg that's what i think
i would have 100 percent stop
you just kidding i'm i'm with you for
the safety you just can't
not see anything definitive
yeah i believe that that is
apparently not you're not allowed to do
that
but but you said even after this beating
he was close to like choking him out the
dude's incredible commentary he was yeah
and and he has anyone let's say he
stopped in the third or taken one the
fifth round and it was one of the
rounds of the year
and he got a so and that's the other
thing so they're in it for money right
yeah they're prized fighters yep so if
you stop that fight you you're
ineligible for the fight of the night
right and he got five the night so you
got an extra fifty thousand dollars
which is a ton of money too okay
yeah
not worth it but okay you know all of
it's i i have a big problem with it i
was fighting it i would have stopped it
you should stop it when you have
something when you see that
you just i if maybe before you have
doctors you know yeah well the doctor
didn't stop it
yeah he might have been inexperienced
and a little bit influenced by the crap
yes it was a dumb but even not to do it
but even with him saying he can't watch
it but it was you know i'm saying
not to fight stop that it's not he won
the fifth round if he would have got
beat up in the fifth i would agree with
he did get beat up he won the fifth
round it doesn't matter he took so much
more it does matter the judges gave him
the feeling he took so much more damage
than those last two rounds and by the
way but yes
it's also a title fight
this isn't a regular fight night this is
everything that he's dreamed of don't
care title fight don't care not for you
leave cameron live to fight another
fight it's the second time you've taught
a shot the chance him getting back there
is
not great maybe maybe just one shot for
him you know maybe that maybe that's the
case well not for yours coach i'll never
get it
no he'd live to fight more and he
wouldn't have brain damage i mean it's
what they do be no no ray damage
you you there is a way to protect
somebody from getting that kind of brain
damage not not a ton of [ __ ] if i'm with
you if there's a regular like fight
night like main event but for a title
fight you can't you just can't yeah
okay
that's not the game
yeah i don't i don't like it anymore
than you do that's just not the game
it's just not what these guys do it's
just not
yeah it's not what they sign up it's a
brutal sport it's the brutal sport yeah
it really is yep it bums me out it
[ __ ] really does it bums me out yeah
it's a tough he's such a he's that kid
is young and such a good looking kid and
so talented and i hate that [ __ ] i just
hate it it's [ __ ] dangerous man when
you see these guys connecting like
volonovsky such a [ __ ] animal
king kickers you know that's mixed
martial arts the highest level
you know i guess so that's just what it
is is there a way to not get hit in the
face that much of your brian o'take it
takes a little while to change his
fighting style yeah well
so could nick diaz
like how do you not have this argument
for nikki although i'll tell you what i
see with nick diaz i see much better
defense when i was watching nick what
impressed me about that was him in that
in the corner kind of deflecting moving
he just knows how to he sees
that but there's no head movement
there's no footwork but a lot of those
shots were glancing i was really
impressed but a lot landing he broke his
nose and then he sat down and quit yeah
yes but nick was always pretty good at
getting avoiding that stuff you know but
he has fights of the night saying slug
outs and that's what he's known for and
you love him for it that's why he has a
fan base i loved nick because nick i
never saw nick really get hurt the only
time i saw nick get hurt was he got
dropped by paul daley and then he dude
he's got some leftover wars though
that's some more the business yeah again
but but also but also with with nick
like
that's the reason he was like right i'm
out yeah like there's no yeah i'm out i
mean how much can you do after a while
you see this stuff you see it what's
interesting to me is you just see these
wars wear on people and they're warriors
but you just
it just starts to give you either glass
jaw or just it just you know that's the
game b unfortunately that's the game
there's got to be a better way to
protect the people like that
turn into grapplers
like like nick diaz has some of the best
juicers in the world so
you know for nick if he didn't want to
eat those punches or save his brain
cells yeah grapple more dude yeah well
what's go tell nick diaz what's funny
about those guys is if you have two
grapplers they just don't [ __ ]
grapple they just stay punched in the
face yeah they're just like i'm going to
[ __ ] bang with you because i don't
want to have you get positioned on me i
don't want to get tired you might turn
the corner and punch me in the face but
think of brian ortega it's like he has
such an advantage in grappling over a
volcano right but he really doesn't he
didn't attempt taking well his coach
said hit him with a blast double hard to
do yeah easier said than done with those
[ __ ] legs and all that but the thing
about we fought max holloway straight
striking one he took so much damage yeah
so again so to your point the only way
to for you to be comfortable watching
mma is these guys need to grapple more
well someone cuz that's why we don't get
brain damage like you see curtis blades
yes i don't think i mean he could fight
tomorrow yeah
he got neat in the [ __ ] head well
that's like khabib that was like john
fitch a lot of those guys just would
[ __ ] hold you down and punch you in
the face and i get it it's not that
exciting you don't have a career dude
yeah you're not going to get paid the
big bucks but with i mean khabib did
because
his jiu-jitsu is so dynamic even after
taking that [ __ ] i mean that triangle he
almost caught him with that [ __ ]
got out of that [ __ ] it's nuts nuts
that's nuts
i mean he's just able somehow to do it
he's just made of different [ __ ] but so
i if i'm if i'm if i'm ortega's coach
that's what i'm saying i'm saying use
your fanta your jiu-jitsu is so flashy
and special use that [ __ ] then again
then again the higher level guys don't
really care
they just post up and punch you in the
[ __ ] face you can't you just gotta be
careful because dude again dude you
gotta crack some eggs make an omelet if
you wanna make a million bucks you crack
some [ __ ] eggs and you want attention
yep you gotta crack eggs and eggs is
people getting punched and knocked out
and receiving ct it's literally the name
of the game
the name of the game you know what time
it might not be for me for real
how you feel you know what i'm saying
like there's nothing that i do it
bothers me and maybe also these guys are
just so much better at striking it's
what they work on with high level
coaches now with boxers i feel like
they're hitting
more accurately harder i don't know man
i don't know it's like you're better
athletes maybe maybe yeah